mein name ist eva bozen ich bin 28 jahre
alt und ich wurde am 2 zwölfter mit
bayern check gebucht hat seitdem leide
ich vor allem an atemnot schmerzen
permanentes herz stechen
[Musik]
ermüdungserscheinungen und ständiger
fertig
verputzen des deutsche meisterin im
kraftdreikampf hält einige rekorde sie
sei absolut keine impfgegnern sagt eva
aber sie fühle sich mit ihrem
krankheitsbild im stich gelassen auch
finanziell dann habe ich jetzt schon
diverse us space durch das sogar mit
kortison das sind dann sachen wie ja
einfach was was der durchblutung an sich
helfen soll das hier ist ein mittel das
soll mein kopf quasi wieder schneller
machen weil wir alle so ein bisschen
dieses problem mit brain force haben und
dass wir halt so langsam nachdenken
können allein das kostet
270 euro also ich bin momentan bei
ungefähr 18.000 euro aus eigener tasche
das musste eva putzen vorliegen was sie
davon erstattet bekommen wird weiß sie
noch nicht eva hält mit 100 81 kilo den
deutschen rekord in der kniebeuge von
solchen leistungen ist sie zurzeit weit
entfernt ihr wird immer wieder
schwindlig wenn sie trainiert
ja ich muss gleich - trinken im moment
ist eva froh wenn sie einfach
alltägliche schafft das ist für sie
nicht mehr selbstverständlich
und gehen einkaufen gehen ohne probleme
und natürlich auch wieder ins training
einzusteigen
welche krankheit eva genau hat weiß sie
bis heute nicht aber immerhin sie hat
einen termin in der uniklinik marburg
bekommen
auch viel ich sehr binger ist froh dass
sie endlich in der lankowitz
spezialambulanz vor sprechen kann lange
musste die 28-jährige darauf warten es
ist für mich die hoffnung dass jetzt
hier etwas gemacht werden kann womit es
mir dann besser geht oder zumindest ein
paar symptome gelindert werden können
als ich vier dinger mai 2021 impfen
lässt postet sie das video auf instagram
die schauspielerin freut sich sehr
darauf endlich ohne sorgen arbeiten zu
können doch kurz danach geht es ihr
schlecht chronischer erschöpfung
nesselsucht taubheitsgefühle allergische
reaktionen
und dann kamen immer weitere symptome
dazu neurologische probleme ja und habe
dann ein ärzte marathon hingelegt und
gemerkt keiner nimmt mich ernst
hier in der spezialambulanz wird verließ
er grundlegend untersucht
die ursachen von nebenwirkungen der
impfung herauszufinden ist professor
schäfer sehr wichtig die nachfrage ist
groß neun monate müssen patienten auf
einen termin warten die völlig
verzweifelt sind weil sie waren ja im
vorfeld gesund sie müssen herausfinden
trägt dieser patient irgendein bisher
bekannten nicht nicht näher
identifizierten genetischen defekt im
immunsystem wir müssen tatsächlich viele
viele verschiedene felder differenziert
abklopfen um zum schluss sagen zu können
wo das problem bei diesen patienten
liegt und warum das immunsystem nach der
impfung bei dieser patientin falsch
abgebogen ist mir hat noch nie jemand so
zugehört und das so ernst genommen wie
jetzt ist die große erleichterung
in deutschland sind rund 64 millionen
menschen mindestens einmal gegen cobit
geimpft nebenwirkungen werden beim paul
ehrlich institut gemeldet nun ist eine
diskussion darüber entbrannt ob der
anteil der schweren nebenwirkungen mit
0,02 prozent zu niedrig ermittelt wurde
das geht aus einer beobachtungsstudie
hervor die kurz nach veröffentlichung
sehr in die kritik gekommen ist
gesprochen wird hier von 0,8 schweren
nebenwirkungen die genaue zahl sei aber
nicht zu entscheiden sagt professor
mathis ich glaube dass wir in
deutschland ein anderer reporting- haben
was die 0,02 prozent betrifft denn wir
haben ja schon in der als goldstandard
geltenden register studie aus schweden
daten dass im schwere nebenwirkung bei
etwa 0,05 liegen das bedeutet sie liegen
auch da 2,5 fach höher als das was wir
in deutschland haben das paul ehrlich
institut betont dass es sich bei dieser
studie um eine internetumfrage handelt
es keine richtige wissenschaftliche
studie sei soweit daten und methode der
studie der charité bekannt sind haben
wir seitens des paul-ehrlich-instituts
fanden wissenschaftler teilen das
schwächen gesehen und möglichkeiten der
verzerrung der entsprechenden daten ich
kann nur sagen dass die suggestion die
von den verlautbarungen von professor
matthias ausgehen falsch sind die
suggestion wäre dass wir nicht bescheid
wüssten welche nebenwirkungen die
welchem ausmaß nebenwirkungen der
zugelassenen kurve die impfstoffe
tatsächlich da sind dass es nicht der
fall wir wissen aufgrund der bei uns
zehn millionen fachen aber weltweiten
jahren einfachen impfungen mit diesen
impfstoffen im detail welche
schwerwiegenden welche weniger
schwerwiegenden impfreaktionen passieren
fest steht viele betroffene fühlen sich
mit ihren beschwerden nicht ernst
genommen
in marburg gibt es eine der wenigen
spezialambulanzen mit ersten ergebnissen
der eigenen forschung
wir sehen in unseren grundlagen
untersuchungen erst gefunden die in
richtung einer
gefäß schädigung gehen wie wir sie bei
einer klassischen
herzmuskelentzündung finden einer
sogenannten myokarditis also die ersten
sehr vorläufigen befunde zeigen dass es
hauptsächlich
junge frauen sind im reproduktions
fähigen alter so im verhältnis 3 zu 1 zu
den jungen männern es sind aber alles
junge menschen
hauptsächlich aber nicht nur
mein name ist frank meyer bin 62 jahre
alt mit einem 13 fünfter letzten jahres
mit buy und tag geimpft worden zum
zweiten mal sechs wochen danach etwa
oder bei mir eine autoimmunerkrankung
festgestellt
mein name ist heiko engemann ich bin 54
jahre alt bin am 9 521 das erste mal mit
buy und kämpft worden danach nur leichte
grippesymptome ein tag und am 20 06 21
mit der zweiten impfung auch bei unter
vier stunden später danach hatte ich
eine halbseitige gesichtslähmung
die beiden haben die impfstelle auf
schadensersatz und schmerzensgeld
verklagt vertreten werden sie von
rechtsanwalt joachim cs april aus
wiesbaden
frank meyer macht die kogit impfung für
seine autoimmunerkrankung verantwortlich
ein neurologe hätte den verdacht
bestätigt
und er sagte mir das könnte schon
durchaus sein dass es durch die impfung
zumindest demaskiert und getriggert
worden ist
ja ich habe mich dann an das robert koch
institut mit dem online antrag im
internet gewarnt den habe ich dort
ausgefüllt mehrere seiten lang da kam
aber niemals mehr was zurück ich habe
echte hinter mir da lag ich empfehle ich
konnte kaum atmen hat einen großen
becher dabei weil mir die spucke aus dem
und quasi raus gelaufen ist also das
wort ganz furchtbar
heiko engel man macht die impfung für
seine damalige halbseitige
gesichtslähmung verantwortlich
etwas getrunken und dann ist mir alles
aus dem mund rausgelaufen da denke ich
was ist jetzt los aber gedacht und gut
auf wird eine nebenwirkung seien von der
impfung und wird morgen weg sein das
ging dann so dass dann nachts das auge
nicht mehr zu gehen und am nächsten
morgen meinen aus angerufen dann gesagt
sofort rettungswagen rufen ins
krankenhaus könnten schlaganfall sein
meiner meinung nach ist eine kausalität
dazu der impfung
also sie haben das immer abgestritten
und haben gesagt oder nach der sache
geforscht das ist was anderes sein
müsste
autoimmunreaktion neu aufgetretene
hashimoto zwei knoten in der schilddrüse
schubweise auftretend probleme
nervensystem kopfschmerz
rechtsanwalt joachim cäsar preller
betreut in wiesbaden rund 250
mutmaßliche geschädigte täglich werden
es mehr
eher selten sei es einfach den
zusammenhang der krankheit mit der
impfung zu belegen
im bio kadett ist drei tage nach der
impfung oder sinus venenthrombose fünf
stunden nach der impfung also da kann
dann auch wirklich
der dagan skeptisch gegenübersteht
eigentlich umhin und und das anerkennt
alleine die behandlungen die viele
patienten selbst zahlen müssen ja zum
beispiel eine blutwäsche ja die kostet
7000 euro pro behandlung bis 12.000 eur
wie will man das denn eigentlich
dann selbst bezahlen das ist auch ein
teil der entschädigung die wir im
übrigen einfordern damit die leute eine
anständige soweit möglich ist versorgung
bekommen und vielleicht dann doch noch
die hoffnung haben auf heilung
auch willig sehr binger hat diese
hoffnung die 28 jährige dankbar dass sie
mit ihrer krankheit nach der impfung
endlich ernst genommen wird
ich hoffe dass die therapie und die
medikamente also dass sich zudem 85
prozent gehöre wurst anschlägt und habe
jetzt zum ersten mal hoffnung dass es
mir besser geht in ein paar wochen
ihre booster impfung liegt mittlerweile
mehr als sieben monate zurück eine
wirkliche besserung sieht eva putzen
bislang nicht
seit monaten notiert sie täglich welche
symptome sie hat müdigkeit husten lungen
schmerzen herzlichen
ich wünsche mir vor allem dass nicht nur
ich sondern auch alle anderen
geschädigten ernst genommen werden dass
wir keine angst oder sorge mehr haben
müssen zu einem arzt zu gehen und da
einfach offen darüber reden können und
auch einfach die hilfe finden die wir
benötigen
und dass da in naher zukunft einfach
medikamente oder mittel gibt damit wir
schnell wieder auf die beine kommen zum
einen natürlich damit ich wieder normal
arbeiten gehen kann und zum anderen aber
auch weil ich unbedingt zurück in den
sport möchte
jetzt geht es erstmal darum wieder
alltägliches zu schaffen dazu gehört
auch mit ihrem hund spazieren zu gehen
eva ist froh dass sie bald einen termin
in der uniklinik marburg hat
sie möchte endlich wissen was ihr genau
fehlt und wie ihre krankheit zu
behandeln ist